he is one of the best in the business he
is an NBA champion head coach from back
in the day with the Celtics trying to
bring one to Los Angeles with the
Clippers which just finished out the
April of of 2019 like a house of fire 13
and 2 and the Clippers getting set to
take on the Rockets coming up on
Wednesday which would be the 3 6 matchup
should everything stay chalk from here
on out the rest of the way he is none
other than Doc Rivers how are you coach
you know what al hasn't invited me to
play golf lately so yeah I I don't know
I I know he likes to keep the course to
himself now that it's been redone you
know I know that you know but it's it's
all good it's it's great to chat with
you either way let's let's start with
your team here so trading away Tobias
Harris did not end the season like a lot
of people thought that the the Clippers
had given up what was that like for you
to to absorb and and go into the locker
room and say let's keep rolling here
well you know it's funny you you have to
do what's best in the long run I think
that's where sometimes as a coach that's
hard to do you know you're looking at
the team you're looking at it with
suppliers and bogey and Mike Scott
you're rolling yes at that time we're
still like an eighth seed fighting for a
playoff position but before a year no
one thought we were going to mystify
offs and now all of a sudden we're in
this place you know Lorenson staff calls
and tells me this is what we said in and
what do you think we would like to
Detroit with a Kotori horse o for a long
time and what we didn't know if it was
for short term so going and first of all
tell them Tobias absolutely long as a
feather guy you know then going into the
locker room I would made it worse I
remember the day we traded them or the
night that for him that night he knows
it in one shot
you called him up to the room and he
does anything Ethan
you want we want to talk about playoffs
and instead I'm telling him pay and I
were trending you you know and that was
hard and then going to the lucky little
you know the next day I put the guys
there at that moment they felt like wow
we've done all this and now we just give
up on a season for next year and it's my
job to really let them know we're going
to go for it we can still do this
honestly I didn't know it's good or not
at the time I knew we're going to try
and I think know how good the other guys
were when I little Sam it's come in and
been great zubats been amazing to
Michael's been great now Wilson just
start playing so we actually added to
our team and we didn't know it at the
time so have you ever experienced
anything like this is a player or a
coach we're not no you know no you know
in Boston trading Kendrick Perkins but
all those trees were made either we are
already a bad team and we were just you
know I've given up and we're trying to
you know stock up for the draft or we
made a change because we thought it'd be
a better trade for our team to make us
you know a better play on team but to
take away the best player in the middle
of the season that you're already having
a surprising season and you got a bunch
of guys who fought in your program
completely that was hard that was really
hard and I was fortunate miss lab I have
Lou Williams at better in a locker room
and they they made it you know I had to
talk to them first and tell them guys
we're not giving up on the system we can
do this it's going to take an
extraordinary uh you know job by all of
us and it's going there or by you guys
get everybody to buy in but those two
guys did it I mean they they really so
to everybody we can still win and I
thought those are the two guys and gal
that helped me sell that we just still
do this now obviously you've got your
own locker room you got your own
situation but you know the town in which
this has taken place and you could you
could hear it and Patrick Beverly's
voice after the Clippers beat the Lakers
recently and you
the night that that you guys clinched
and remind a lot of folks about the
naysayers at the beginning of the season
and predictions what does it mean that
you have had this month of March and
this ascendancy in the same season that
LeBron comes to town in in the same
building and they are just sputtering
and spinning their wheels what does that
mean you know I can tell you I really
never gave any thought to them by the
Lakers you know I just didn't I Dakotah
focus on your eyes and your song oh it's
in that clueless either you know you
know that you know the Lakers got all
the attention coming into the new year
and let's be honest a [ __ ] up James
going to him and so I didn't make that a
problem
neither team is proven in today um but
they've got more attention because they
have one of the greatest players to ever
play the game
don't take that personal that has a
challenge that you're going to steal
makes your day and I think our guys did
what's it like to have Jerry West on on
the team here and I've known them for a
long time obviously you know from
bel-air yeah but just the fact that now
he's on my side I mean it's just an
extraordinary for me and for Lawrence
and the entire staff yes it's just when
he is it like the old EF Hutton
commercials when he talks people listen
I mean well yeah after what exactly I
think that's where he does his best is
evaluating talent and he does a great
job that he miss you know and he gets a
lot of input and that's I you know
everybody you know rich you spend your
life and same with me you find out that
the people who do stuff well listen well
and get a lot of information and then
that have the ability to take that
information and make a decision and
that's what he does and it's interesting
in this day and age doc you know and
just going to use the example you're the
the co-tenant if you will of staples
they're right there with the Lakers is
any team that talks about improving
themselves through free agency which is
a lot of the part of the game about
trying to put a team together to win a
championship certainly with the Warriors
in your in your division and Conference
that that it's messes with the minds of
the people that are currently on your
roster are you brushing up on July 1st
speech are you getting ready for that
while being mindful of obviously what
you've got cooking here is the six seed
going into the game in Houston up to be
honest now I mean obviously that's gonna
come um but I think I bet this is what
we're doing now and I think the way this
team plays how this team acts
how does team gets along how we function
how we run our organization I think
that's our seat you know and and then
you know once that comes I think then
I'm hoping that all the guys who are
considering us not only look at you know
me are the Colts but also let's at the
organization and then they look at the
players to get to play with Wow you know
and so I think all that is part of our
speech and so I don't work on it I think
about it much and I'm doing more for now
well in terms of that you know we just
leave it there for the second were you
focused at all on the tournament and she
double-a tournament each other on that I
would focus more early you know when you
see Irvine was playing because I had a
son my youngest son Spencer was playing
on that team I also you know just
watched Marquette because that's my alma
mater unfortunately they had a quick
exit but then you know televizzle and I
are very close and so I'm very very
excited for him he's wanted to get guys
we worked together on one of the u.s. 18
years ago with me him and Flip Saunders
and he's been a dear friend ever since
so I'm just really happy for him so what
did you think when when coach was front
and center in a conversation about
coaching - Hardee's player Aaron Henry
and he was in the kid's face and how
he's in his the kids and amateur athlete
not a professional and the coach and be
as demonstrative what did you think of
the over coaching or coaching too hard
conversation I don't I don't know you
know I think that times obviously if
it's you know a competition that turns
into a physical something or another but
I don't think that was the case you know
do know time when he looks like he's
talking to you yet that expressive face
so it looks a lot worse than it is
no Tom Izzo at all oh but it's amazing
now you know you coach the guy and now
people who don't know coach you know
haven't been around it they ask
questions about it and you know it's
funny I don't mind that because I do
think there's times that it has got oh
um but I didn't think that was one of
them at all
oh I just started his coaching his guys
and the clearly respond to him because
look over that and you know of all the
coaches fall you know he's one of the
guys that all the players come back
their novel oh he's doing it the right
way I can tell you that and who's the
one that you can compare Zion to the
most food are played with or you've
coached or you have tried to draft and
just put him in perspective as to how
generally generationally talented he is
right now if you had to and this is not
a slice because Charles is one of the
greatest players to ever play the game
in Berkeley but he's an athletic Charles
Barkley or an actor and I use a
combination of Charles Barkley and
gerrymandering but then add the
athleticism see and when you think of
that because I think what people are
missing with Zion is is brain and that's
what that's very mind so well it's just
such a smart IQ high IQ flair for things
I didn't have the emotions right but
it's that's what I
no but it's just amazing to watch it and
in terms of a couple more minutes left
with Doc Rivers in terms of draymond you
know he tweeted out over the weekend the
initials TD and a lot of people thought
he was referring to the old official Tim
Donaghy based on what he thought was a
call against his team is there is there
an officiating problem in the league
with relationships just now I'm not
talking about the ability to make the
call but we've heard Chris Paul and
James Harden say that a specific referee
is biased against Chris we now have this
with draymond is there an issue in the
league Duncan I don't think so I think
the only thing we have is unfortunately
we have the perfect storm of a lot of
the veteran officials have retired it's
been injured and we have a lot of design
decisions coming in but I don't think in
a sense in this issue come at all it's
out of fact I would say there's days
where I'm not happy with the officiating
in those days that I'm happy with your
face there's also days that I'm not
happy with my coaching and they
stoughton many famous players no it's a
human game that's going to be geyser
that's the most difficult game to
officiate I really do and if you want to
every call all bow you know if you
wanted to make it that way so it's a
judgment game and whenever it's judgment
involved when I get them all right then
that doesn't mean nothing to happen with
them all the time to vendors express it
as any coach out there but at the end of
the day I've never thought that once
that there's a bias and it's also this
human it's done sometimes where you say
oh man I don't know if I get along with
this guy that's fine not human to me and
that can happen and then just live with
that and you're trying to make it better
that's what we're last one for you the
Bears have the opening kickoff of the
2019 NFL season against the Packers doc
I mean that's a big fat piece of bears
filet mignon for your fan base I swear
that was a brutal laws last year
Kevin said that I loved in with playing
the Packers
I don't want to replay of the first time
the practices that was lost in his own
right but I really believe it's gonna be
hard to beat the Bears this year I
thought you see if it didn't got by that
game there would have been hard to beat
so I'm big on chevensky I love the team
I think yeah if the field goal had
gotten through as opposed to the double
doing cos Cris Collinsworth your buddy
Al's colleague would say they were
coming here to Los Angeles doc I mean
they were gonna be right there in the
backyard they were coming you know oh
you ever replay that before the tape and
I tell how I was yelling at the screen
right it was like he knew something was
going to happen and instead of like
three times
oh boy oh boy and I was like I
appreciate the call of look forward to
having you in here when when you when
you've got a chance maybe before the
draft I'll be great you the man doc
thanks for the call you know that's Doc
Rivers Clipper head coach here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience